en Irán están de celebración decenas de
miles de ciudadanos salieron a las
calles de Trump para conmemorar el 44
aniversario de la República islámica
cuando en 1979 un levantamiento popular
derrocó alza respaldado por occidente
este año he venido más gente tras los
recientes disturbios la gente ha venido
a demostrar su lealtad a la revolución a
su líder y a su país
este año tras dos aniversarios con
restricciones por el covid-19 la gente
pudo caminar hasta la emblemática plaza
azade y ondear banderas con consignas
como abajo Estados Unidos o abajo Israel
y cargar retratos del líder supremo de
Irán el ayatola aleja meney con
celebraciones en al menos 1400 ciudades
del país según la televisión Estatal
Aunque empañadas por un fantasma de
fondo las protestas de los últimos meses
tras la muerte de Max a mini tras ser
arrestada por la policía de la moral
en los últimos meses los enemigos de
Irán han reunido todas sus fuerzas y han
desatado una guerra colectiva esta
situación nos ha demostrado que en estos
44 años no apreciamos la Revolución y
hoy a la luz de esos acontecimientos he
venido con mi familia y mis dos hijos
pequeños
pero no todos piensan igual muchos
exigen más libertades y respeto a los
Derechos Humanos lo que el gobierno
califica como disturbios ya han dejado
cientos de muertos y miles de
detenciones de personalidades públicas
desde periodistas y abogados hasta
actrices y cineastas